attention ce soir pour notre révélations
j'accueille et je vous demande
d'accueillir dark vanneur d'alzheimer
celui qui fait la guerre aux étoiles
l'homme à la vanne laser star tu veux
dire stéphane guillon donc bon soir
soares que pour que vous vous
reconnaissez dans ce dans ce surnom
c'est un journaliste qui a trouvé ça pas
mal je réalise que tu es en forme
et voilà donc je l'assumé ja boucher de
berne aussi pas mal alors on va faire un
petit peu votre votre bio dont vous êtes
d'abord un humoriste qui panier en
banlieue donc est pas née dans les
quartiers à neuilly-sur-seine c'est une
banlieue oui c'était une banlieue mais
ça c'est d'ailleurs on a une fausse
question internet qui dit pour un
humoriste vaches à renaître à neuilly
dans une famille aisée
est ce que ce n'est pas déjà se payer la
tête des gens parce qu'on en a les
moyens
c'est un outil internet un autre c'est
une question intelligente oui voilà
c'est ça normalement écoute moi je
je pense pas que le lieu où on s puisque
oms a autorisé à dire ou à ne pas dire
certaines choses parce qu'il ya des gens
qui ont beaucoup de talent et qui
viennent de trappe comme djamel voilà
ayant des gens comme moi à l'origine
d'un oeil aussi s'il ya des gens qui ont
moins de talent qui viennent de neuilly
je parlais à d'autres fans de bailly
mais un petit peu pourri mais chut
alors unir par contre un itinéraire
plutôt classique
j'aime pas l'école même rond bien donc
je la quitte à 18 ans on peut préférer
de saison 16 ans oui l'école m'a quitté
à 16 ans et les petits boulots et les
petits boulots bages en effet plaint le
premier spectacle premier spectacle
c'est en 91
un spectacle qui s'appelait c'est dur
pour tout le monde je jouais au movies
qui était à grands comme
le bar à peu près après ça a été petites
horreurs entre amis ça a été quelque
chose qui a fait démarrer les choses non
oui enfin petite erreur entre amis m'a
permis de démarrer au fou du roi de
stéphane bern et de fil en aiguille il
ya eu canal plus et ça ça a été un
booster énorme puisque les gens sont
venus en masse me voir en salle quoi et
le spectacle qui est derrière nous
stéphane guillon en avant les musiques
formule épicée c'est à dire si une
reprise en plus corsé j'ai créé le
spectacle oui voilà c'est ça exactement
j'aurais pas dit c'est très bien ça
n'aurait pas dit mieux merci mais je
vous rendez vous qu'est ce que jésus
avant de faire le pitch à ma place
c'est l'ancien spectacle un petit peu
plus musclé quoi j'ai aussi été un
plaisir donc du 21 septembre au 30
décembre au palais des glaces alors on
ne jouerait pas le 31 alors mais ça
m'ennuie c'est à 9 h 30 et un jeu c'est
peut-être une erreur
1 parce qu'il paraît que c'est la
meilleure date ouais ou le 24 décembre
le 24 décembre qui joue que devant des
gens seuls ces sinistres à un diable
alors dans les vacheries parce que ça ça
m'a l'air d'un livre qui en contient
quelque chose du jazz sont bien sûr et
même y en a quelques-unes devraient
quelques siècles et alors est ce que
c'est un tel un dictionnaire c'est un
dictionnaire mais dedans il ya eu déjà
quelques j'allais dire quelques échos
est ce que c'est vrai que là qu'il
cherchait par exemple à ce que benjamin
castaldi a vraiment voulu le tuer
me tuer je ne sais pas mais je pense
qu'il aurait volontiers aurait
volontiers molesté même ville un métier
risqué
oui voudraient qu'on pourrait paraître
viderait en revanche c'est un certain
regret pour moi c'est un souvenir parce
que mon seul contact finalement avec
shell jacques villeret était un contact
de
de haine entre guillemets en tout cas de
de vives tensions alors que tu admires
d'abord c'est un acteur que je que
j'admire et ensuite on a eu le même
professeur d'art dramatique était jean
laurent cochet donc même formation
théâtrale et c'est vrai que j'ai
regretté d'avoir eu ce ce seul contact
avec viderait qui était un contact de
alors on va donc donc là si tu veux je
me fâche
s'il vous plaît ils vont pas ils vont
pas apprécier le fanion souhaite vous
expliquer quelque chose et il aurait
besoin de votre attention
je me suis demandée
ce que seront devenues nos stars
préférées en 2030
et donc voilà j'ai trouvé un
dictionnaire des noms propres en 2030 et
on commence par exemple lire amanda
homme de télévision célèbre
c'est normal c'est dit qu il peut rien
elle bh oui mais à shell dans le
dictionnaire clb à chien s'est inversée
philosophe marié à barbie casse-noisette
reporters de l'extrême notamment au
palace l'éden roc où il dénonçait la
qualité épouvantable du room service
alors attend d'eux fontenay geneviève
fontenay variétés de pommes de terre
c'est occuper d'endives de monaco albert
prince à la vitalité exceptionnelle
descendance
oh lalala lalala mon dieu mon dieu et on
a des enfants pour reconnaître ses
enfants la principauté mis en place un
numéro vert
même pour les enfants de couleur béart
emmanuel actrice française remportant en
afrique le titre très convoité de miss
bush en plateau voilà qu'est ce qui se
passe
des fans ça alors qu'on les fans parce
que les fans
la définition d'un pas terminée grâce au
format 16/9 elle plus jusqu'à la fin
brasser ses partenaires s'en sortir du
cadre
jackson michael anciens noir blanchi en
2005 animateurs de centres aérés morts
en 2012
bambi repose à disney à la droite de
pinocchio quand les enfants touchent
pinocchio son et grandit quand il touche
bobby de censure faut censurer cette
année maison raisonnable de neuf
catherine non touche pas à catherine
deneuve et nana c'est déjà fait delanoë
bertrand à mr notre mère inventeur des
couloirs de bus de 6 mètres de large
quand le bus s'emmerdait ils pouvaient
zigzaguer
mathieu mireille essaya toute sa vie de
lancer la mode de la coiffure playmobil
petrucciani michel
pianiste de jazz parce que là ça va
inspirer fortement le sculpteur césar
quand il fit ses compressions burban on
se fait plaisir
sarkozy nicolas d'une fille hommes
politiques les dicussions marié six mois
sur 12
d'origine hongroise il quitta la france
après sa défaite à la présidentielle de
[Applaudissements]
victime de sa propre loi sur
l'immigration choisie
reconverti à budapest dans une
entreprise de karcher
nicolas propreté qu'il vous faut bon bon
petit dernier pour la mois dernier
oui zidane zinedine
don sur l' attention catcheur français
grâce à un magnifique coup de bol zizou
sauva la france in extremis d'un
deuxième titre de champion du monde
un geste technique parfaitement
maîtrisée grâce au footballeur ribéry
qui lors du mondial offrit son visage
pour entraîner son idole
[Applaudissements]
st paul villot reconnu le dictionnaire
de stéphane guye guillon se fait femme
ancienne langue de [ __ ] à cannes à cet
immense comédien décroché le césar en
2008 2009 et 2010 ce n'est pas tout on
retiendra surtout la standing-ovation
qu'il reçu à l'émission le café picouly
bien sûr un public conquis scandant
saillants et tapant des mains je n'en
voyais
[Applaudissements]
confort et des menaces
du 21 septembre au 30 décembre on peut
les médias
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]